foreign
Oregon's gun laws are about to get a bit
stricter by a narrow margin 50.7 percent
oregonians pass measure 114 back in
November
50.7 percent measure 114 measure 114
bans the sale transfer or manufacture of
magazines with more than 10 rounds of
ammunition and requires a permit and
background checked by a gun today a
federal judge approved the measure well
it all comes down to the permitting
process Jeff and Elizabeth and we've
heard some Sheriff's offices do not know
what that new permitting process is
going to look like and if it is not in
place within the next three weeks when
the law goes into effect that new law
means that gun sales will have to cease
it's just been total chaos in here just
a lot of customers coming in wanting to
get in before there's any changes you
know they're all just kind of scared and
they're just wanting to get stuff before
it's taken away things are very active
on the gun control area in the state of
Oregon right now the residents passed
measure 114 which did several things at
banned magazines that hold over 10
rounds are required a permit to purchase
and required a training course
application fee fingerprinting and
duplicative background checks in order
to obtain the permit to be able to buy a
gun in order to exercise your second
amendment rights it passed by a razor
thin margin of course
um you know the the Portland area kind
of tipped the scales the rest of the
state was very much against this this
measure everybody just has questions and
nobody has any answers you know there's
just so much confusion out there when
does it take effect who's affected by it
when are we gonna you know so when is
the last day they can purchase a gun if
they purchase today can they pick it up
later you know nobody knows anything we
don't have any answers we don't know
where to get answers it's just confusion
all around
it started off with a lot of you know
really nice people coming in and just
like we really appreciate you being open
taking care of us
um you know they're starting to get a
little bit of frustration around the
edges since we don't really have any
answers for them you know they are kind
of upset you know they're not happy that
you know this didn't pass by a large
margin this isn't really what the
majority of Oregon wanted I believe and
you know they're frustrated they don't
understand why they can't get some of
these things and why it's being taken
away and you know that kind of turns
into some anger at times we went to the
state court as opposed to the multiple
lawsuits that have been filed on the on
the in the federal court challenging a
measure 114 on the Constitutional Second
Amendment uh violation we chose to go to
the state courts because we believe that
measure 114 is in violation of the
Oregon Constitution and the Oregon
Constitution is analogous to the Second
Amendment so we thought that that was an
important place for us to make the this
argument and to show that
this measure goes contrary to the Oregon
Constitution and we believe that it
should be defeated
probably around 100 backgrounds a day
but that doesn't include customers
coming in looking for mags looking for
ammo coming in and picking up their
purchases previous purchases you know
I see a lot of people and it's a
constant flow from that unified that
we're open
my understanding is that it was
happening not only in the rural areas
but even in the Portland gun stores that
they were lines around the corners you
know trying to to acquire whatever they
can and and we very much encourage that
when people feel that their second
amendment rights are in Jeopardy the
first thing they do and it's the wisest
thing they do is to go out and make sure
that they have all the firearms that
they think they might need or want we
encourage everybody to go to your local
gun store buy the the firearms and
ammunition and magazines that you think
you're going to need or that you want in
order to protect yourself your family
your home your businesses now's the time
to do it
foreign